はい それでは次のスライド
次のテーマに行きます
もう苦しみとこの仏教的な楽しみと苦しみの仏教的な分析
生きるということはね
どのような働きでしょうか
生きるという働きと幸福
不幸の問題が出てくるんです
これはこれから仏教の話になります
苦楽の仕組み 第一のステップ
見る 聞く 嗅ぐ 味わう 触れる
思考する その内容によって幸福
楽しみを感じたり また苦しみを感じたりする
そこまでお分かりになると思います
ずいぶんシンプルですね
どこで苦しい幸福を感じるかというと
見る 聞く 嗅ぐ 味わう そんなところでしょう
苦しみもそういうところでしょう
それでちょっとした説明
目の対象は楽の原因にも苦の原因にもなる
同じ 全部同じなんです
例えば 音を聞いて幸福を感じるならば
音を聞いて不幸も感じる
何か食べて美味しいものを食べて幸福を感じるならば
同じく舌で苦しみも感じる
この五分五分はなくなりません
何か考えて楽しく興奮したならば
変なことを考えてすごい落ち込むことも可能です
したがって 外の対象に依存しても楽しみのみを得られる保証はありません
それで人間何をやっているのかというと
物に依存する 家やら土地やら建物やら
会社の立場やら服とかね
いろんなものになぜ依存しているのかというと
楽しみはやってくるでしょうと
品 外の品物から音楽にも依存するでしょうに
豪華な家具にも依存するでしょうに
しかし そういうものは楽しみだけ運んでくれると思っていることはものすごく勘違いで
楽しみを運ぶものが苦しみも同じく運ぶんです
それはもうどうにもならないんです
原子原発と同じです いつでも金が幸せを運ぶというならば
金がまた不幸も運ぶんです
それで仕組みに見えるもの
音などの外の世界を自分の感覚器官で感じるんです
それで見えるものやら音やら香りやら外にある
我々には感覚器官があるんです
感じる器官が それで感じるんです
感じなきゃどうにもならんですね
現象 感覚器官に触れると
苦の感覚 楽の感覚 不苦不楽の感覚が現れるんです
これは仕組みの 第2位です
何か目に触れると楽しくなったり
嫌になったり あるいはどうったことないということになったりとかね
それで感覚は 3種類あるんです
音が触れると楽しくなったり
嫌になったり どうったことになってどうったこともないということもあったり
3種類 それで現象は流れる
これ ちょっと皆さんに分かりにくいでしょうね
音の場合はわかるでしょ
音がスーッと発生して流れないと音ではありませんね
他も同じなんですよ 本当は
絵画を見て楽しいと思っても
そこからスーッと情報が流れてくるんです
流れて目にぶつかるんです
音を流れて耳にぶつかるとことと同じ
香りも同じでしょ 香りがスーッと空気たどってきて
鼻にぶつかる またたどってきて鼻にぶつかる
この流れてこなきゃ認識できない
できないんです 一回微妙に香りが鼻に入ったっても
もうわかりもしないんですよ
ずーっと香りが流れて鼻に触れ
流れて鼻にくる そうすると
あ なんとか香りがあるんだと認識するんです
この目のことだけ皆様に分かりにくいんですけど
音なら分かりやすい 香りなら分かりやすい
味も同じことです それから
誰かが私の手をこうやって捕まると
私は感じますよ しかし
こちらも流れなんです
捕まった手のエネルギーがスーッと流れているんです
自分の体に だからまだ取られているんだ
まだ取られているんだとわかるんです
これ 腕相撲とかやるとよくわかりますよ
男同士で腕腕相撲する
こちらはずっと力入れてるんです
向こうもずっと力入れられてる
それでエネルギが流れてるんですよ
そこで誰かのエネルギの流れがもうそろそろになったところで負けなんです
だから体に触るものも
ずっとエネルギが体に流れてこないと
感じることはできないんです
気持ちも常に変わる ですから
私の体にある感覚器官の感覚あるでしょう
感覚も同じスピードで流れるんです
音が触れる 感じる 音が触れる
感じる 音が触れる 感じるなんです
これはもうどんな科学でも計算的数学的には言いにくいんだけど
まあいい加減な子供っぽい数学は入れられますけど
で 例えば 1 秒間どんな速さで
これはあのヘルツで言ってるのは
この流れなんですよ 音はなになにヘルツとかね
光はなになにヘルツとか
この波の波長を言ってるでしょ
この波の波長で何言ってるのかというと
この品物が触れるスピードなんです
それはもう科学者の世界ではもう波にしているんです
ということは 音はどれぐらいですかね
音の聞こえる範囲は  30キロヘルツから
例えば 30 キロヘルツといえば
1 秒間に何回変化するかってことでしょ
キロヘルツですからね
で 何回ですかね そうすると 33
えっ 3000回 もっとでしょ
3万回  1 秒に 3万回変化する
これ一つ一種類の音ですよ
今 30 キロヘルツの音ですからね
またいろいろあります
光はもっとものすごい
それでこの皆様 電波やいろんなものはヘルツで計算するんですからね
それは 1 秒間に何万回
何千万回変化するのかということで
それで覚えてほしいのは
その分子が耳に舌に目に触れるたびに
感覚も同じヘルツで変化するということなんです
同じヘルツ数で変化しなきゃ感じないんです
微妙な差がありますよ
微妙な差があると ちょっと認識が変です
ちょっと変になるだけ
はい それであまりみんな気にしないこと
外の情報が絶えず流れている
それ認識しようとすると
自分も絶えず変わるんです
感覚が すごいことですよ
さん 三十...三分間音楽聴いたと言っても
ただ聴いただけでは終わってないんで
こちらもかなり激しく変化したんです
その間で はい ここまでは問題になりません
自然の流れどうにもならん
こちらには感覚がある
音があったらもう触れてぶつけて
空落 空楽 不苦不楽生まれる
まあ単なる自然の流れ
例えば水が流れていると水の音を聞こえる
どうったことはないんです
そういうわけで この第二に
二で あの こちらで書いている苦
楽 不苦不楽は自然の流れ
止めることは不可能です
止める必要もありません
で 仕組みの三になってくるとどうなるのかと
外は寒い時も暑い時も体で苦を感じるが
暑いから私は不幸だという人はいません
当たり前のことだからね
今は外に出たら暑いんですよ
なんて不幸でしょうかと誰も驚かないでしょ
ああ 不幸 すごく蒸し暑くてきついなとか言うだけで
なんかどこかクーラーあるところででも探しましょうとかね
これで落ち込んだりとか
なんて人生は不幸でしょうかと思いません
なぜならば 自然の流れ
全然精神的な問題は起こりません
対象に依存する弱い心は感覚器か
感覚器官...入るかな
に入る情報ではなく 体の感覚を認識したり評価したり
また感覚に執着したりする
第三番目にどうなるかというと
この体に感覚が生まれるでしょ
この感覚を評価するんです
人に音は聞こえませんよ
音が耳に触れて感覚の波が落とす起こるんです
大体波長似ています 我々が認識するのは自分の体で起こる感覚なんです
だからぴったし同じ波長が起こるということでもないんです
だからものを見ても見えないものはあります
この色の検査とか お医者さんやってるでしょ？お医者さんが色の検査やってる
やったならば 色彩に対して自分の弱みがあると発見するんであって
本人は知りませんよ それでもよく調べるのは色三つだけですからね
もっとすごい色いっぱいある
あるんですけど だから我々に全部見えるわけじゃない
例えば絵画は自分持ってる色は全部出してます
全部出してますけど 私たちの目で振動を起こせられるものしか感じないんです
よくテレビで見たことであって
この花にはすごい色があるみたい
しかし 我々に見えませんと
紫外線も認識できないと
だからこの紫色もあります
見えない紫色 で このスペクトラムの左側
右側ももう一つ 色のライン 2つあるんだけど
人間には見えない しかし
蝶々やら鳥たちやら その生命には見えるんだと
それでなんでこのつまらない花でもしっかり遠くから見るかというと
これで紫外線も感動できる
カメラで撮影してみたら
つまらない花じゃないんですよ
派手に色があちこちついてるんです
それらがどんな遠くから見ても見えるんだよと
なんでこのアフリカのもうそんな高い木もないのに
草ばっかしで見事に動物隠れてるでしょう
色は見えない ほとんどみんなに
私は驚いたのはこのゾウなんですよ
あんな巨体で ただ草あるところでも隠れます
別にしゃがんだりはしませんよ
ゾウは これ人間にも見えない
私に見えなかったんだから
もう野生のゾウですけど
もう一人ゾウっていうのはすごい怖いし
で いるということで見ようかな
見えなくなった どこ行ったかと
言うともう一人 え？こちらいますよと
そしたらもうそばにちょこっと隠れ
ちょこっと隠れてるだけ
それだけで見えないという
すごい見事なカモフラージュというかね
だからそれは自分の視力の問題でしょ
だからゾウは人間にも隠れたい
シマウマはもう人間の目には派手に見える見えるでしょうね
まあこの人間の一緒に生活しないんだからそれでいいと思いますけど
もし人間いるところでシマウマもいたならば
やっぱり人間に見えないようになると思いますよ
それから人間であろうが誰でも
あの食物連鎖のね 一番トップにいる虎やらジャガーやらライオンやらね
隠れると人間に見えませんよ
なぜならば人間も餌です
虎にしてみたら そんな尊いものなんでもないんです
獲物が取れない 体が弱いんだったら
まあまずいんだけど これ食ってやるぞと
人間を食べようとするんですけど
まあ人間もっと恐ろしいんだからね
まあそれはそう簡単にはいかない
だから自然界で見れば
人間はライオンの虎の獲物なんです
だから人間に相当訓練しない限りは
そこら辺にいるライオン
虎は見えないんです 虎っていうのはすっごい模様があって
かなりのもう派手なやつ
パンクでしょうに まあ虎は本当にパンク野郎なんですけど
そこに隠れちゃうと見えないんですよ
それ虎は知ってますよ
自分がどのようにいれば見えないのか
思っているかどうかはわかりませんだけど
動物園にでも行ってみてください
動物園ではかなり面積の中で自然の中でいられるようにしてますから
結構見ること苦しいんです
あまり植物はないんだけど
ちょっと下で横になったら見えない
そういうことで だからこの見えるもの
全部見えるわけじゃない
私の目が波長を作らないと
だから我々私に見えるものは私の感覚セット
これはウェーダーな体とパーリ語で言いますよ
で 感覚の体系組織 五蘊の中にウェーダナという一つですからね
で そのウェー 絵が振動しないと
で感じない そこで人間
次に何にするかというと
この感覚を感じた 感覚を認識したり
判断したり 評価したり
いろんなことを頭の中でやっているんです
だから 外の絵画と関係ないんですよ
絵画から一部のデータしか感じてないんです
目でその感じたものについて
こちらギャーギャーギャーギャー頭の中でいろんなことをやってます
それからすごい執着が生まれるんです
おかしいことはあの絵が欲しいと思うんですけど
えらい勘違いです 自分の目に生まれた感覚なんですよ
自分の目に現れた感覚が気に入っちゃって
なんてすごい幸福な感覚でしょうかと
それであの絵を欲しいと言うんです
主観的な妄想によって楽しみも苦しみも生まれてくる
それから第一ステップで感じた苦か楽か生まれた
第二のステップで感じたものについて評価したり
考えたり 判断したり ごちゃごちゃ勝手なことを主観でやっています
それによってまた苦しみか楽しみか生まれてくるんです
この二次的に生まれる苦楽は
一次的に生まれる苦楽よりも強烈です
それで一時的な苦楽がありまして
二次的な苦楽があります
自分勝手に合成するものなので
拡大すること 増幅することはできる
だから 絵画が与えたデータと関係なく
自分勝手でいくらでも興奮することはできます
鬼の絵を見て怯えちゃって失神することまでできます
悪夢を見ることもできますよ
また 他の人にはただ鬼の絵ですねとか
まあ別にということもできます
それは二次的な世界なんです
危ないのはこの二次的な世界なんですよ
虫に刺された痛みでも殺人を起こす
犯す怒りまで拡大できるんです
実際 虫が刺されただけ
それで痛いんですよ しかし
その痛い感覚を頭の中で増幅して
増幅して 怒って怒って人を殺すところまで拡大することは可能です
だから 頭のいい人々はそちらに気をつけるんです
ただの虫ではないかということで
だから人間 ちょっとしたことで人を殺すでしょ
車を運転する ちょっとクラクション鳴らしただけでもう飛んできてぶん殴ったりするんだから
そこまでやったのかと
どこか外で人を見たところで
あ かわいいなと思った瞬間で
それただもうかわいい人を見てかわいいと思っただけで
それからその感覚を増幅するんですよ
増幅で増幅で その人は私のことを徹底的に気に入ってるんだ
もう私が守ってあげないとストーカーになるんです
相手は全く知らない それでストーカーになって
やがてその人を刺したり殺したりもする
だからこの二次的な苦しみ
楽しみ これがもうどうにもならん
大変なことなんです これで苦楽のディファレンス大ですね
二次的な苦楽は現実的なものではありません
この二次的な苦しみ 楽しみは現実的じゃない
妄想です 個が作るものです
ですから 幸福は一人一人違うんです
なんで幸福は一人一人違いますかと
科学的じゃないでしょう
科学的じゃないのは これ二次的で頭で勝手に作るんだからなんです
だから幸福はあくまでも自己責任なんです
虫に刺された 痛いのは虫のせいなんです
蚊が刺したところで痛いのは
それは蚊が悪いんです
だから言って殺してはいけませんけど
その痛みはすぐ消えるし
私を蚊を刺したっても
他の人蚊に刺されたっても
その苦しみは同じですよ
一次的な苦しみは科学的な現実
二次的な苦しみは妄想で生まれてくる
現実ではありません だから
個人個人の幸不幸の世界が互い違う
同じ環境でいても 同じ楽しみ
同じ苦しみを受けないんですよ
で 貧しい国に生まれた私から見れば
日本人には何の不幸もないでしょうと
困ることも全くもないし
楽に生きていられるんだと思う
思いたいんですよ  ちょっと体を動かしちゃえばお金が入るし
それで仕事っていうのはもうむちゃ簡単ですよ
日本って何の能力もいらん
パターンで受ければいいんだからね
例えばマクドナルドでバイトにバイトするんだと
いきなり行ったらもう絵を描いても
それ見ながら組み立てればそれで終わりですよ
すごい簡単です それでそれなりに生活できる水準でお金はくれてます
払ってます だから何が問題ある？私は自分の国でもう朝何人かお寺にいるんだから
もうご飯はなくて じゃあパンでも
もう子供たくさんいるんだから
やっぱりもうなんかパンでも買って食べさせようかなと思って店に行ったら
パンは売り切れというんです
それが問題ですよ いろいろお坊さんたちやら子供たちやらいるんだから
そんなことは日本ではあり得る？ないでしょう
なのにこれがまあなんか地獄のセットみたい
あのユニバーサルスタジオで作ってる
なんだこの苦しみ なんだこの人殺しとかね
自分の国でも人殺しやりますよ
だってあらゆる争いあるんだから
いろいろからくりを作ったりして
金儲けのために それも逆に言えば
もうそういろいろ貧しいんだからでしょうし
この国でなんで子供が子供を殺してますかね
まだ知ってる子供ならいいんですよ
もう腹が立って喧嘩して殺し合いになったと
そうでもないでしょう
ホームレスの人を蹴ったりして殺す
だからまあ危ないのはこの二次的な世界なんです
妄想が作り出す世界なんです
だから日本の環境を見ると
一次的な場合は苦しみじゃなくて結構楽しみが生まれますよ
環境を見たら 綺麗でしょうし
こういう建物に入ってみたってもすごいかっこよくできているし
電車に乗ったってもすごい気楽に行けるし
ちょっと喫茶店 ちょっと喫茶店なんとか行ったら
ちゃんと有線放送で音楽は流れているし
どこで苦しみはあるのかと
だからもっと理性があれば
すごく穏やかにニコニコと笑っていられるはずですけど
なかなか笑わないんですよ
その代わりに二次的なところでかなり激しく苦しんでいるんです
それは個人差があります
だから同じ環境でいても幸福は同じじゃないんです
残念なことに 二次的な感覚に束縛されるんです
それがとっても残念なことに
一次的な感覚にはそれほど束縛されません
川を見て ああ 楽しいやと思うだけで終わっちゃうんですよ
しかし 心で生まれる印象はなかなかもう
消えません 消えることできないということは回転させますからね
その印象を 回転させて拡大して増幅して
いろいろ変な形にして
いろんなもうゲーム遊びやってます
頭の中で それで 4番目
内面で作った苦楽は外の原因対象で現れたと勘違いする
病気もそこから内面で自分が作るでしょ
苦しみやら楽しみやら
それはその人のせいであの人のおかげやと思っちゃうんです
違うでしょう 母親のせいで自分が苦しんでいるんだと
よく言うこと 母親は何もやってないでしょ
ただもう洗濯するは料理作ってちゃんと用意してあげるわ
毎日ワンパターンでそればっかりやってるでしょうに
朝寝坊すると毎日小さい時から起こしてあげるわ
これ大人になったっても
どうせ大人になりませんから
日本人は だから母親が起こしてあげるわ
何もやってないんですよ
特別なこと なのに母親ぶん殴ったり
あなたのせいで私は不幸になったとか
あなたのせいで学校勉強できなかったとか
これはもうブッダにも治療できないぐらいもうもう壊れてます
精神は本当にそうなんですよ
母親に攻撃したら たとえお釈迦様がじりじり来たっても
もう不可能です よくアンブリマーラ大長老のエピソードを覚えておいてください
999人殺したと言うでしょうに
まあ数字はちょっと怪しいんだけど
しかし わざとそのエピソードを書くのに
なんでそこまで黙って
お釈迦様 一人の人を殺したところで言った方がいいでしょうね
あるいは将来もそれなりに見えるんだから
誰も殺す前に行って説法した方が良かったのに
どうせ阿羅漢になる徳があるし
阿羅漢になる徳があって生まれたら阿羅漢になりますよ
そこまでなんで待っていたんでしょうかということもあるでしょうに
まあ理由は 2つ 一つはもう全然仏教なことに興味ない
もう学者だから もう学ぶことにもう鬼
先生言うことは神の言葉で
それ以外何も耳は傾けません
だからお釈迦様が言ったっても意味がない
まずお釈迦様は忙しいんだから
その日でその日で悟る人に説法してるんだから
順番待ちですよ 結局は
だからこの間でこの人は結構やっつけたんです
人々を しかし 王様がこの泥棒を捕まえようと出たところで
お母様が王様に殺されると
私の一人息子がかわいそうやとこそっと隠れて連れて行こうではないかと
森からと思って出かけたんです
そこでこの人は長い間人殺しかやってないんだから
もう母親はわからないんですよ
だから最後の1000人目の人で終わりですから
彼の約束は 神との約束は
ですから 誰が来たっても殺すんです
そこでこのエピソードで書いているのは
もし彼が母親を殺したならば
もうアウト終わりだと
たとえ知らなかったとかね
そんなことは聞かない
知っていても知らなくたっても母親のそれより先にお釈迦様が
いくらなんでもそれだけはやめてちょうだいよと
そこでお釈迦様は割り込むんです
割り込んで話し合って
もうちゃんと出家に入って
それから阿羅漢にもなる
だからそのエピソードよく覚えてほしいんですよ
母に手を挙げたっていうことが相当なことなんです
手を挙げるだけじゃなくて
母に対してかすかに怒りでも憎しみでも持っていると
もう人生はもう捨てたことにした方がいいんです
自分の幸福 あの業全部もう穴だらけでもう全部漏れちゃいます
だから たとえ母親が確実に鬼そのものであっても
母親なんです 鬼で何もやってくれないかもしれませんよ
家に来たらもう包丁を持ってもうもう刺そうとするかもしれませんよ
それだったら自分が逃げたらいいんです
しかし 怒り憎しみを持ってはならない
その権利はないんです
自分の業が幸福になる
善行が全部消えます 残るのは悪業だけ
それから 人間は善行も悪行も持ってますよ
善行が全部消えちゃうと
相当相当危ないんです
それでこの勘違いの話
それで私たちの愚かさのあまりに
絵画を見て自分で妄想して楽しんでいるのに
欲しいな 欲しいなとかね
それで珍しい豪華な絵画であっても
これをどうやって強盗できるのと計画立てたりする
盗まれるでしょ 結構盗まれちゃいますよ
最近ある雑誌で読んだんだけど
リストあるんですよ 盗まれたすごい豪華な絵画とかね
値段も書いて インシュアランスも書いて
こういうものは国際的に探してはいるんですけど
こういうものは決して見つからないんだよと
一旦盗まれたら ということをやって
どうせ裏の世界で回すんだよと
だから決して表舞台に永久的に出てこないんです
誰かがお金を払って買っても
家で飾るわけにはいきませんだから
自分で盗まなくたっても
もう自分がすごい高い
何億円も払って買ったっても
買って飾った時点で持っていかれます
自分一応有名なものは盗まれたということは世界に言うんだから
知らないで買ったわけじゃないんです
そう 人はあのなんとかオープン
なんて言いますか あれ
競りみたいなものあるでしょ？競りで買うんだから
競売で だから永久的に表に来ないんだよと
それで私たちが あれのせい
これのせいやと思って外に文句を言うんです
悪いことしてるのは自分なんですよ
この妄想でいろんなことをやっていることなんですけど
それ勘違いが生まれますね
好ましい情報に触れると幸福になり
好ましくない情報に触れると不幸になると誤解に基づいて結論に至る
だから私の幸福 私の不幸は
この環境の問題であると
私は大丈夫である 何も悪くはないんだと
そういう結論に至るんです
それから何するかというと
物に執着したり 外の世界と戦ったりして
第3次の苦しみを作るんです
だから 苦楽のステージステップ 3つあります
第1だけ自然現実です
第3ですね 我々はとっても苦しんでいるのは
金も借りたいし もういろんな競争に出たいし
もうあれ いろんなことでオリンピックに出てメダル取りたいし
サッカーでも勝ちたいし
戦争までするし 人間と喧嘩するし
なんで人と喧嘩するんですかね
自分の苛立ちはその人のせいだと思っているんです
それで敗北するための挑戦しています
だから人類の生き方っていうのは挑戦ですよ
みんな挑戦してるんですよ
生きることに それはもう敗北するためにやってるんです
世界のものを自分のものにしようとする戦いは敗北するに決まっている
何一つも自分のものになりませんよ
何一つも自分のようになれません
この体も自分のようになれません
体には体の勝手な法則があるんです
自分言う通りに動くものは何一つもない
例えばコンピューターなんかは人間がプログラムしているんだから
人間の希望通りに動いていると思っているだけで
そうじゃなくて プログラムとコンピューターが自分の法則を持ってるんです
その通りに動いて動いているのであって
こちらの希望を聞いてるわけじゃないんです
それは明らかに人間が作ったもんでしょ
人間が徹底的に神様のごとく全部自分で作ったんです
それでも人間の話は聞いてくれないんです
神様と同じなんです 神様は人間を作ったんですけど
もう神様の話は人間聞いてあげないんです
いくらか豊かになっても
一切を捨てなくてはならないんです
戦って戦って いくらか幸福になってしまっても
全部捨てます 惨事の戦いでは
楽より人は最大限に苦味が増すことになる
この第3次になったところで
ステップになったところで
もう世界で戦ってますから
苦ですよ その時はもう
楽もあるんだけど ちょっと仕事をして
ちょっと儲かったら楽しいなと
しかし  1ヶ月間も仕事をしなくちゃいけないんです
だからトレッドステップになってくると
ほんのわずかな楽があるんだけど
苦かなりあるんです 苦楽の仕組みをまとめてまとめてみると
人は少々の楽しみと最大の苦を感じる生き物であることは理解できると思います
人間っていうのは 少々の楽しみとすごい最大の苦を感じる生き物なんです
かわいそうですけど 正しく言えば
蚊に刺されたら痛いとかね
外へ出たら夏だから暑いとかね
それ苦しいんですよ 蒸し暑いとかね
それぐらいの苦なのに
実際やるのは 満員電車でハイヒールの女の人に足を踏まれたとか
これ結構痛いんですよ
でもそれってどうったことないんですよ
その痛みは消えちゃうし
たとえ怪我したっても治るし
問題は 2次 第2次の苦
これが絶えず続くんです
次に勘違いして外のせいやと思って人々と戦ってるでしょう
その場合は苦しかないんです
だから計算してみてください
どれほどわずかですかと
我々はこの世の中で生きていて
感じる楽しみはという
と